turning now to our other main story
today u.s president joe biden has
declared the climate crisis is here in
the wake of devastating floods caused by
storm ida more than 40 people have died
in northeastern states some drowning in
basements others swept away in vehicles
the storm is thought to have caused tens
of billions of dollars in damages rescue
operations are still underway and
transport remains limited in major
cities including new york
biden says the u.s needs to rebuild to
prepare for a future of intense weather
the flood waters have gone revealing the
destruction from the remnants of
hurricane ida
flash floods crashed through this
neighborhood in queens new york
in danyong's home
water poured through this wall
he and his wife were trapped in the
basement as the water rose fast
the water goes to my left
so
my neighbor in the second floor
he
hold my hand and then i hold my wife's
name
and my dad's hand so we can
get out from the
from the basement
as communities take stock of the storm's
damage
stories of lucky rescues are emerging
and tragedies too
in this block tenants tried to save a
neighbor after waters surged up from the
sewers into her flat
so then the tenants heard her she was
screaming help me help me help me we all
came to her aid trying to get her out
but it was so strong of the water you
know the thrust of the water was so
strong we could not peel the doorbell
and dozens more lost their lives
ida hit the state of louisiana on the
u.s gulf coast as a category 4 hurricane
on the weekend
it weakened to a tropical storm but grew
more deadly over the states of new
jersey and new york
bringing record rainfall to the region
turning major roads into rivers
and stranding cars and lorries
[Laughter]
new york state's disaster planners were
not prepared
this is the first time we've had a flush
a flash flood event of this proportion
in the city of new york and in the under
outlying areas
we haven't experienced this before but
we should expect it the next time
u.s president biden is facing calls for
federal help from many u.s states this
summer
the past few days of hurricane ida
and the wildfires in the west and the
unprecedented flash floods in new york
and new jersey
is yet another reminder that these
extreme storms
and the crime of crisis crisis are here
we need to be much better prepared we
need to act
this isn't about politics biden is
promising more investment to make the
country's infrastructure able to
withstand more devastating storms like
this one
disasters that are becoming more common
meteorologist matthew capucci is
covering this story joins us now from
washington matthew more than 40 are dead
in the northeast of the u.s from a
widely anticipated storm how come so
many people were caught off guard
that's a really good question i think so
few media outlets are actually accepting
the fact that it was widely anticipated
so i very much appreciate you mentioning
that
honestly i think it's the biggest
challenge and the biggest dilemma facing
forecasters is that even the best
forecast the most exact accurate weather
forecast we can make still does no good
if it falls on deaf ears or if it's not
really received or
interpreted by the public correctly and
so ultimately being a meteorologist
entails doing two things a being
scientist to produce a forecast but
being an effective communicator and
we thought that we did a good job
getting the word out apparently we
either didn't or
there there's some sort of missing link
to what it is that we do but we're gonna
be going back and trying to figure out
why so many people perished when we
thought we knocked it out of the park
you say that there were predictions or
warnings were given
and you talked about the importance of
communication
why did the communication these early
warnings not get through to those people
what what went wrong
i think
so often people when they see the
forecast for something either atypical
or extreme
they tune it out because we have so much
these days in the media that is
unfortunately either
incorrect information or misinformation
that when there is a legitimate source
of of information that
sounds a little bit far-fetched i think
people just kind of write it off for
example
this was the first time that the
national weather service ever issued a
high risk alert for flooding in the
united states in the northeastern u.s
rather this far in advance this is the
first time we ever had a flash flood
emergency in that part of the world
there were a number of firsts with this
event but
i think so often
when you have big stories these days
that
you know are real stories but
you know come in an era when
misinformation online reigns through
it
people just tune it out
so
the message may have gotten lost in the
noise does ida still have the potential
to cause more damage matthew or is the
worst now ever
the good news the worst is now over we
have cobalt blue skies building in its
wake temperature is dropping feeling a
little bit cooler nice and crisp behind
it actually feels really comfortable
outside it's a good fall air mass
but it completely believes the danger
and the fury that ensued just 24 hours
earlier it was that clash that gave rise
to these very strong storms and really
this clash that is almost poetic where
from destruction you have beauty
matthew thank you very much
meteorologist matthew capucci there in
washington